uh his wife and his mother-in-law are
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase involving Paparazzi photographers
and that is from Prince Harry's
spokesperson we'll get you more on that
as and when we can here on Sky News just
that short amount of detail coming into
us at the moment
uh well now there is a warning that the
global temperature is set to break a key
heat limit for the first time within the
next five years the World Meteorological
organization said it is now considerably
more likely than not that it will breach
the key 1.5 degree limit it says there's
now a 66 chance we will pass the 1.5
degrees global warming threshold by
2027. in 2015 countries agree to pursue
efforts to limit Global temperature
rises to 1.5 degrees you may remember
that was under the Paris agreement
in 2020 it was predicted there was less
than a 20 chance of breaching 1.5
degrees in the five years ahead let's
hear now from our climate change
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter the
World Meteorological organization makes
predictions every year on the likelihood
that temperatures will rise Beyond 1.5
degrees above pre-industrial levels in
the following five years and this is the
very first time those scientists have
said that there's a 66 chance so it's
more likely than not that temperatures
will do so they've said it's very
worrying but but potentially temporary
we could bring those temperatures back
down by a sharp reduction in emissions
for example why is this happening
emissions instead of coming down are
going up and with it heat we've seen the
drought droughts for example around the
world in southern us ongoing droughts in
Europe that won't change unless
emissions start falling but it's been
coupled with the emergence of a weather
phenomena climate phenomena called El
Nino which tends to be associated with
warming oceans and with hotter air
temperatures this though is a
tremendously symbolic moment you
mentioned that 1.5 degrees of warming is
a symbolic number around which all the
climate discussions at U.N climate
Summits and Beyond have been orientated
scientists and diplomats and policy
makers know that we're already at 1.2
degrees of warming we don't have very
much time to limit warming to 1.5
degrees and there is real fear amongst
climate diplomats in particular that if
1.5 degrees of warming appears to be
crumbling then this critical shared
consensus will start to ebb away and
Nations will start to reneg on promises
to do their best to limit global warming
senior metropolitan police officer has
defended the forces actions during the
king's coronation saying he was not
pressured by the government into
cracking down on protesters temporary
assistant commissioner Matt twist
appeared before MPS this morning
following criticism of the way officers
handle demonstrations
I felt under no pressure politically I
felt pressure to deliver a safe and
secure operation but that was because of
the fact it was a once in a lifetime
event for so many people and there would
be hundreds of thousands of people in
London to celebrate it the stakes were
enormously high so I absolutely felt
pressure to deliver a safe and secure
operation but that wasn't political
pressure that was the pressure to do a
good job
but ironically the hearing about the
best way to police demonstrations had to
be briefly suspended when it was
interrupted by a protester this one from
just stop oil
you usually use a combination lock to
stop and
we're here today
[Music]
right we're now back in session
to be clear they would just stop oil
protesters who tried to undermine the
activities of this committee with our
Witnesses today
I just want to bring you a little bit
more on our breaking news this afternoon
the news involving Prince Harry his wife
Megan and Megan's mother adoria Ragland
we're hearing from Prince Harry's
spokesperson that all three of them were
involved in what the spokesperson is
calling a near catastrophic car chase
involving Paparazzi photographers the
incident happened after Megan and Harry
had attended an award ceremony in New
York yesterday the spokesperson saying
and I quote this Relentless Pursuit
lasting over two hours resulted in
multiple near collisions involving other
drivers on the road pedestrians and two
NYPD New York Police Department officers
that is the quote from a spokesperson
for Prince Harry in a short statement
that has been released this afternoon it
was the first public engagement of
Prince Harry and his wife Megan in New
York yesterday since the coronation of
King Charles The Duchess of Sussex in
New York appearing on the red carpet
alongside her husband and her mother
before receiving a woman of vision award
at a Gala ceremony the prince of course
Prince Harry involved in court action
here in the UK against mirror group
newspapers and also another Court case
involving so security arrangements for
when he and his family visit the UK but
what we are hearing from Prince Harry's
spokesperson is that there was an
incident after that ceremony in New York
on Tuesday that lasted over two hours
and was near catastrophic in its
consequences a car chase involving
multiple Paparazzi photographers it
doesn't specify but it may be that this
happened after the ceremony last night
although it doesn't specify that
just to bring you again what this short
statement says
Prince Harry his wife Megan and her
mother were involved in a near
catastrophic car chase involving
Paparazzi photographers the incident
happened after Megan and Harry had
attended an award ceremony in New York
this Relentless Pursuit lasted over two
hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers that is all the detail we have
at the moment no word as to how the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex or indeed
Prince Harry's spokesman clearly wanting
to highlight what had happened
particularly given the couple's
narrative on press intrusion and
standards uh that are not in their
opinion uh upheld by certain areas of
the press indeed as I said Prince Harry
in the middle of a big high court legal
case brought alongside a number of other
high-profile figures against the mirror
group newspapers
that court case ongoing the court
hearing evidence from former journalists
immigrant newspapers today of course
we'll keep you updated on the course of
that here on Sky News but that breaking
news involving the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex involved in a near catastrophic
car chase involving Paparazzi
photographers after they attended an
award ceremony in New York yesterday it
lasted over two hours and according to a
spokesperson from Prince Harry resulted
in multiple near collisions involving
other drivers on the road pedestrians
and two NYPD officers so it seems like
it was a Relentless Chase but luckily it
seems that everyone uh the couple her
mother-in-law and those involved in
those near misses
escaped unscathed we await more detail
on that in the meantime let's bring in
our role corresponder Laura bondog
um Laura as I've been saying very little
detail about what happened I've been
enough to give us a sense of how serious
it was for the couple and Megan's mother
yeah I mean the details we have are slim
at the moment but by the sounds of it it
was a pretty
very frightening evening for the three
of them we know that they had been at
this Gala in Manhattan a little earlier
in the evening Megan was picking up a
woman of vision award for her work
promoting women and girls who've been
presented with the award by Gloria
Steinem she'd made a speech photos have
been taken of them arriving and then
photos of them getting into what seemed
to be a yellow taxi as they left the
awards now I don't know if it was at
this point that the paparazzi started
their Chase we simply don't have those
details but from what we've heard from
this uh spokesperson statement for the
couple saying that there was what's
being described as a Meer catastrophic
car chase involving Paparazzi
photographers and of course I mean does
it goes without saying some very
frightening Echoes obviously of what
happened to Diana here clearly a very
scary moment for the three of them in
Manhattan and something areas touched on
hasn't he and so many of his his recent
interviews he's given something he's
spoken about in his book as well this
horrible fear of being out with his
mother in the car and just being chased
and chased by photographers having to
run red lights as they pursued her
relentlessly so as I say at the moment
the details of this particular incident
uh we don't we don't know much more at
the moment but we do know that it was a
Relentless Pursuit it lasted more than
two hours and seems to have resulted in
multiple mere collisions involving other
drivers and not just drivers but
pedestrians and police officers as well
that's according to the spokesperson for
the couple but we get more details of
the see we'll update you
Lord this just gives us a sense of the
appetite for the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex in tabloid terms because of
course I was just talking about the fact
that this was the first public
appearance of the couple since the
coronation of King Charles
and
the whole world wants pictures of them
they want to see what they're up to so
it harks back to that era that you
mentioned Prince Harry is so passionate
about ending you know of the Tabloid
culture of the paparazzi it seems that
you know that isn't dying away when it
comes to this couple no and I I
got my words Prince Harry will be
furious about this he will be very very
angry I mean his his this destructive
dislike of metabloid press is well known
as well documented it's come up time and
time again in the court cases he's
pursuing at the moment
um this is exactly the sort of situation
he doesn't want the couple live believe
it or not it relatively a secluded life
where they live it's outside actually
even sort of the main city in La
um they they shy away as much as
possible from big events at the moment
but when they do come out clearly the
photographers the world's press focus on
them and and that is something that has
always happened and I think because we
haven't seen so much of them recently
and Harry flew in and then flew out
again didn't he for the coronation we
barely saw him he obviously wasn't there
on the balcony he didn't take part in
any of the other events around the
coronation we simply saw him arriving at
the service attending the service and
then leaving straight after the service
to head for the air where he flew back
to America this is this is how they want
it at the moment so I think when we do
see them together as a couple out in
public there is going to be this huge
interest around this and I think as much
as they try and control the narrative
and to try and as much as possible
control them easier around them
um it seems that there has been this
sort of Relentless pressure to get the
photos given the limited opportunity
there is to see them out in public uh
together I mean they get so perhaps
don't they in and out of restaurants
occasionally but there's public housing
is not something we see very often and
and
um it's just it's a frightening sort of
echo as I say of the sort of late night
car chase through a busy City and it
seems that
um you know there were crashes involving
other cars that pedestrians perhaps had
to scramble out of the way even the
police who presumably were there trying
to help them make their way
um through the chasing Paparazzi um got
caught up in in all of this at the
moment that we sort of await more
details at the moment but it sounds like
a very scary evening
um for Megan and Harry and Doria who we
understand was Megan's mum who was with
them as well at the time and Laura
what's Prince Harry has put out there in
the public domain this afternoon feeds
into the two court cases he's involved
in in the UK one about
um phone hacking and the levels that he
believes you know the Press go to to
gain access to his private life but also
the one about security and what kind of
security he has given when he comes to
the UK with his family obviously and
that is going through legal proceedings
at the moment and when you look at
what's just happened or what Prince
Harry's spokesperson is saying is
happened it sort of you know it feeds
into that narrative from the prince as
well it's almost you know him putting
out this statement through a
spokesperson and saying look look at
what's happening
yeah I mean I think the the interesting
court case was obviously Harry's Harry's
sort of fight against uh the phone
hacking cases there was a trial taking
place at the moment involving mirror
group use cases he's got similar actions
that aren't quite at trial stage with
the Publishers of the sun and the
Publishers of the mail as well and he's
made it clear that he wants to change
the media landscape now of course a lot
of the phone hacking refers back to
um to sort of practices that he's
alleging were taking place a while ago
but I think this sense that he was
fodder for the newspapers they were
pursuing and pursuing him purely to sell
uh their newspapers purely for headlines
without any regard as to the impact it
would have on him as a person that is
why he's taken this campaign and is
taking as far as he can don't forget
he's going to appear as a witness
himself isn't he at the high court in a
couple of weeks time a really unusual
step and so you listen to the way some
of the other Witnesses have been grilled
uh throughout this this trial so far
it's it's a big thing to put himself
through but that such as the anger he
feels clearly about the phone hacking
but also the wider issue of the sense
that he was public property that the
media felt they could go to any extreme
to chase him for a story whatever that
meant but regarding this incident
clearly it it followed this night out
this award ceremony in Manhattan there
are apparently pictures appearing on
social media now as I say some of those
images we were talking about showing
Harry and Megan and her mum Doria
Ragland in a taxi what looks like a
yellow taxi in New York
um and this idea that it was just near
catastrophic car chase the spokesperson
Saint was at the hands of a ring of
Highly aggressive Paparazzi a Relentless
Pursuit that lasted over two hours and
resulted in near collisions with other
drivers pedestrians and Muslims so um uh
um NYPD police officers as well
uh Laura let's just uh bring you the
statement that was released by Prince
Harry's spokesperson we'll read to our
viewers if you're just uh joining us uh
wherever you are the breaking news is
that uh Prince Harry his wife Megan and
his mother-in-law mother-in-law Doria
Ragland have been involved in an
incident uh the spokesperson saying last
night the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and
Ms Ragland were involved in a near
catastrophic car chase at the hands of a
ring of Highly aggressive Paparazzi this
Relentless Pursuit lasting over two
hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers NYPD of course the New York
Police Department
um Laura it's short and to the point
and when I say to the point as we've
been discussing Prince Harry will very
much want to make his point where this
is concerned as you said the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex living away from the
Limelight in the main we have seen some
ironically Paparazzi shots of them going
into restaurants recently but there's
been such a huge appetite for the couple
especially since the king's coronation
and Megan's absence she's been very
quiet since the prince for instance
published his autobiography since the
coronation this has been her first big
public outing I know and I think that's
that's very interesting looking at this
we really haven't heard or seen from
Megan I mean ever since I think the
Netflix series came out I think there
was a sense perhaps that this was
Harry's moment that he had a memoir a
story to tell that he had the subsequent
interviews he wanted to give he wanted
to embellish to be asked to talk more
about the contents of his book and
clearly I think the coronation the
couple felt was the moment where Harry
was there just his father that if Megan
had come then there would be this media
circus around her arrival that almost in
a way I think should have been damned if
she came down if she didn't and perhaps
it was simpler for Harry to come to Mark
the occasion to be there for his father
which we know would have meant a lot to
the king rather than have Megan and
Harry come and then all the questions or
all the kind of coverage that it would
have
detracted I think away from from the
king's big moment there and I think the
fact we are now seeing Megan out in
public for the first time in a while at
an awards ceremony shows us how much
interest there is in the couple still
and and the fact that you know these
presumably are our American
photographers pursuing them and the sort
of sense that they could try and control
the media coverage as much as they want
it is just impossible perhaps in this
day and age that there are newspapers
there are magazines there are you know
all sorts of media Outlets who will do
what it takes to get a photo of the
couple because we haven't seen them much
and I would be surprised if we don't
hear from her or there isn't some sort
of response because as I say this is
exactly what he's campaigning against
what he's spoken about
um at length in his biography and those
interviews the the constant intrusion he
felt growing up I mean when he had his
mum with him how he would be in the back
of the car she would be dodging the
photographers that would inevitably
follow them wherever they went
um and then obviously growing up as a
team without his mum feeling that his
whole life was being exposed by a
tabloid press that did anything to sell
their newspapers so we haven't heard
from the Duke of Sussex but I would
expect there will be some sort of
response following this and we don't
know how they are we don't know where
they are at the moment so lots of
unknowns at the moment clearly
um a different time zone in America as
well but it sounds like it was um a
frightening experience for them all yeah
Laura I'm sure we'll find out more
details in due course we just have that
short statement from Prince Harry's
spokesperson but as you said pictures
have appeared on social media just while
you were talking I had a look and you're
quite right there are a couple of
pictures on social media of what appears
to be well it is the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex and Doria Ragland in a Yellow
Taxi in New York and that does raise
questions about the couple security
given you know
the battle that Prince Harry is having
at the moment in the court about
security when he comes to the UK we have
heard the couple talk at length about
the security measures they've had to put
in place living in the United States and
how they self-fund that but it's you
know for the protection of them and
their family
you know it does raise a couple of
question marks as to how they thought
they may leave an award ceremony in a
Yellow Cab
it certainly does especially someone
like Manhattan which is not known for
its free-flowing traffic even if it was
late at night I I think there would be
Security Experts perhaps questioning why
they were taking a taxi while they
didn't have a bigger Convoy arrange
certainly when I think we lost one of
the last times we saw Megan and Harry in
the UK which was back in September the
week the queen died actually the very
start of that week they appeared in
Manchester together
um they certainly weren't getting taxis
when they were traveling around
Manchester I remember very clearly that
they had a convoy of cars that the route
itself wasn't known they weren't giving
any details as to where they were
staying there was a lot of secrecy
around that and the even the entrance
into the building they were going to
take obviously that was a while ago
things have changed slightly but I I
yeah I think you know I can't imagine
we'll see them getting into a Yellow Cab
again if this is the situation they'll
be facing and perhaps bigger questions
as to why they didn't have security with
them telling them that this was not the
best idea that there were Alternatives
however they obviously weren't expecting
the chase that that happened as soon as
they got in that taxi um but
no unsettling way to find that out
perhaps and I don't know where their
security would have been if they were
sat in the car with them we just don't
know at the moment
uh Laura I'm just going to bring our
viewers again that statement if people
are just joining us uh from Prince
Harry's spokesperson regarding that
incident in New York it said last night
that you can Duchess of Sussex and Ms
Ragland were involved in a near
catastrophic car chase at the hands of a
ring of Highly aggressive Paparazzi this
Relentless Pursuit lasting over two
hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers that's literally all the detail
we have at the moment Laura bundock our
role correspondent is on the line with
me now to talk about this and you know
the first thing that happened when I
read this out and the first reaction I
got from our viewers Laura on social
media and in our inbox is the The Echoes
of what happened to Prince Harry's
mother Diana and I would imagine that
may be part of the reasoning behind why
Prince Harry has put this statement out
yes I think so I think he will want to
draw attention to this and he will want
to remind people very clearly what um of
the pressures they face as a couple and
and how
um this this is dangerous and and how
damaging and and very very dangerous it
it is to them
um I I think
um you know the way you know the way
they were trying to get the photos of
them in a taxi goes beyond what anyone
would expect any normal person would
expect and clearly should never come at
the price of someone's safety as they're
trying to to drive away and and leave an
event and
um this Relentless
um pursuing of them has these awful
Echoes doesn't it of Diana and we know
that that's something Harry knew growing
up that she faced the whole time
whenever she left her house whenever she
went out and about he sat in the car
with her as she tried to escape them he
wrote about it in the spare of her
having to run through red light because
they were chasing her there and then she
stopped at the lights they'd be jumping
in front of the car trying to take
photos of her trying to take photos of
him sat in the back he knows what it's
like and this is exactly what he doesn't
want for his own family we know he's
very protective understandably of Megan
and and their two children we we don't
really see much of their children and I
think it's something like this to happen
that is compromising their safety in
such a dangerous way when they had gone
out to an award ceremony for Megan to
pick up an award an event that was meant
to be a moment of Celebration to end up
in something this dangerous
um will be something he he will be very
upset and concerned about no doubt as
well
Laura thank you Laura bundock there our
Royal correspondent I'm going to go to
our U.S correspondent now James Matthews
and to talk about this breaking news the
Duke and Justice of Sussex
and The Duchess of sussex's mother Doria
Ragland involved in what's being
described as a Relentless Pursuit that
lasted over two hours uh by Paparazzi
after an award ceremony in New York last
night James what are you hearing in
Washington
yeah the details are still coming in
Sarah Jane of course but this was an
event last night uh women envisioned
that it was attended by Prince Harry
Meghan Markle and her mother now she was
being honored for
um championing human rights and for
gender equality as well as being an
advocate according to the organization
for women and girls through her
humanitarian and business ventures it is
nothing new for Harry and Megan to go to
occasions such as this in New York I was
at one in December where they were both
being honored and it is very much an
operation of cat and mouse with the
media there is media that wants pictures
of them on the way
on routes on the way into the building
in the building itself and uh they are
reluctant invariably to offer such a uh
such an image and what's happened this
time is that they were in all three went
in the back door to the building uh via
a Hertz rental car offer so there was
clearly a degree of trying to keep some
distance between themselves and uh
Paparazzi in Pursuit I mean Harry is in
particular is news at the moment in the
wake of the coronation there is a
monetary value on images of him and
indeed of the couple particularly at
this time they are hot news to coin a
phrase in terms of what actually
happened in terms of the pursuit itself
that's all coming from Harry and Megan's
spokesman and uh you know as you've
heard in this statement that's been
issued they call it a Relentless Pursuit
it lasted over two hours resulted in
multiple near collisions they don't say
crashes but it involved other drivers on
the road I mean there are many roads
small and large and extremely busy
between any airport that they would use
upon arrival and departure in New York
having fallen from uh from California we
know they are particularly sensitive to
car chases we saw that in the the
Netflix documentary with Harry and Megan
there was a scene in which they appeared
from the cameras inside their vehicle to
be pursued by a cameraman or a camera we
never saw that camera but it clearly put
them on edge and Meghan Markle in
particular was seen uh to be very
anxious at the presence and nearby of
chasing press one thing to point out
Sarah Jane is that this uh incident such
as has been described by Harry and Megan
spokesman it comes in the wake of Harry
reopening the the legal case in an
effort to enable him to pay for police
protection in the UK he's not been
allowed to do that a court has ruled
that has sided with the home office in
terms of not allowing him or access to
police protection or the ability to pay
for police protection in the UK he has
gone back to court to appeal against
that ruling he's taking the home office
to court in an effort to say I deserve
police protection and I deserve the
right legally to pay for it so that is
going on in the background this incident
happens not long after that particular
appeal has reopened in the UK courts but
you know much detail
remains to come out and what imagines is
if this was a Chase over two hours it
won't just be the spokesman for Harry
and Megan that we will hear from there
must have been many eyewitnesses to such
a car chase particularly if there were
near collisions there would have been
participants in the chase if indeed it
was a Chase so what imagines we will
hear from them in due course
um and that really is what it stays at
the moment in terms of hard news it's
coming from the spokesman of Harry and
Megan calling it a Relentless car chase
something of course to which both are
extremely sensitive I mean Prince Harry
has been very public
about his resentment and anger towards
the media at the media's involvement as
he sees it in the death of his mother in
Paris all those years ago which was of
course as a result of a car chase
through the streets of the French
capital
uh James for the moment thank you I just
want to bring you some pictures we have
of the event that the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex attended last night Megan
picking up an award you can see there
Megan's mother Doria on the red carpet
with the couple as well it was after
this event
that this Relentless Chase as it's been
called Relentless Pursuit happened that
lasted over two hours this is the
Duchess of Sussex arriving
in New York
um At The Gala to accept her award and
I'll bring you the statement again
because we've had a bit more detail
added to it
um it says last night the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex and Ms Ragland were
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase at the hands of a ring of Highly
aggressive Paparazzi this Relentless
Pursuit lasting over two hours resulted
in multiple near collisions involving
other drivers on the road pedestrians
and two NYPD officers or being a public
figure comes with a level of interest
from the public it should never come at
the cost of anyone's safety
dissemination of these images given the
way in which they were obtained
encourages a highly intrusive practice
that is dangerous to all involved
statement there from the spokesperson
for Prince Harry let's bring in Ashner
hernak who's following this story for us
from The Newsroom and so that is the
statement in its entirety as we have it
Ashner not much detail but it gives you
an insight into the seriousness in the
eyes of the sussexes of what happened
and also a warning that what happened
shouldn't happen again
it does over two hours is what it says
in its statement and you get the
impression that they are incredibly
shaken up as you would be if you were
being pursued in the way in which this
statement comes across we understand
that in that vehicle was Prince Harry
the Duke of Sussex and his wife Megan
The Duchess of Sussex and also her
mother so Harry's mother-in-law Doria
Ragland who as you saw in those
photographs there were photographed on
the red carpet this was a woman a vision
award ceremony that Megan was attending
she was picking up one of those Awards
she gave a speech last night this was a
novelist being held in Manhattan in New
York and we have seen photos as we've
just seen on our screens of them
arriving but then there were some
photographs taken of them leaving the
event as well it appears to show some of
them on social media at least Megan and
Harry and her mother stepping into a
yellow taxi a yellow New York Taxi
leaving at ceremony of course it's worth
reminding ourselves at this point
perhaps that they are financially
independent they'd look after their own
security they bring in their own
security and it didn't look like they
were traveling in any form of Convoy as
it were as they would have been used to
doing here in the UK but this Pursuit it
sounds like it was relentless and they
talk in that statement
about how this Relentless Pursuit lasts
over two hours and dissemination of the
images that were taken given that the
way in which it was obtained encourages
a highly intrusive practice that's
dangerous to all involved it makes it
seem as though perhaps there were just
numerous flashes from those uh
photographers those Paparazzi that were
following them and dangerously following
following them in the way in which has
been described and if there were you
know if they're traveling at high speed
plus those
um flashes that were that were going on
it must have been incredibly terrifying
experience for all three of them and let
alone the driver of of that vehicle as
well at the moment we don't know where
they are we and we also don't know their
condition understandably they're
probably incredibly shaken up by this
but as James Matthews was touching upon
their Sarah Jane given that there were
these near misses
and near collisions involving other
drivers on the road and pedestrians and
also near collisions with the NYPD the
New York Police Department officers
perhaps we can expect a statement from
their point of view or even statements
from others who may have witnessed this
car chase
but given that this was an event that
they were attending all together
yesterday it was an incredibly happy
eventually Megan The Duchess of Sussex
was picking up an award to then have
their evening ending in this way last
night clearly they are just waking up in
the states it's very early in the
morning over there and clearly they have
just realized that the danger in which
in which they were in and felt the need
to release a statement like this
uh Ashner thank you yes if a couple of
stood in New York it's around quarter to
11 in the morning if they've already
returned to California it's around
quarter to eight so early in terms of
the United States
um this story more details we anticipate
to come out throughout the course of the
day I want to bring in now
format role Protection Officer Simon
Morgan and Simon thank you for jumping
on the line to speak to us about what
has happened you'll have heard the short
statement and the the detail that's in
it can you give us your impression of
what unfolded for the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex last night good afternoon sir
Jane yes I mean I think it's um an
alarming development from the security
perspective and certainly when we look
look back in history concerning the
Duke's mother then we know the way that
that tragedy uh unfolded so I think this
was probably extremely alarming and
distressing for them but I think there's
going to have to be an investigation
maybe from NYPD as to what support
mechanisms
um their security team was able to draw
upon when they were there if any
um and you know what a duration of a car
chase of two hours in this scenario just
seems very a very long time with no
intervention at some point to me
Simon we know that Prince Harry no
longer has Royal protection in fact he's
part of a an ongoing court case uh
trying to get his right to pay for
police protection when he comes to the
UK but they do have private security in
the United States they've been very open
about that and how does that differ from
Royal protection what would have been
involved on a night like last night such
a high profile event with you know one
of the most famous couples in the world
yeah I mean you look at the two slightly
different scenarios where that takes
place here in London or indeed uh in the
us if we look at the U.S scenario then
you'll be working in conjunction with
the Secret Service you'd be working in
conjunction with
um NYPD and they would be adding the
support mechanisms to royalty protection
and the officers that are deployed
overseas a lot more recce would be
involved a lot more of the planning
phase but certainly even now in the
private sector where we work we always
look to work hand in globe with law
enforcement because that's something
that we need the support of whether that
be an intelligence piece not necessarily
any form of physical support but
sometimes just a contact number you know
should we have any issues that we need a
law enforcement involvement so it's
something that the security Team No
Doubt will have a look at to see whether
um they got those right but you know as
you alluded to the Duke started his
legal case again against the home office
and the Metropolis service in relation
to his his perceived right that he could
possibly buy metropolitan police
officers on the protection front one he
kind of comes into the UK so it's a it's
a rather timely event that highlights
some of the risks yeah
the summer just to be clear If Prince
Harry was still within the royal family
and that security sense what kind of
security would we have seen on the
streets of New York would we have seen
roads closed off you know some kind of
NYPD escort I'm just trying to get a
sense of what help they would have got
last night because it sounds like it's
different if you are Prince Harry within
the royal family rather than Prince
Harry as he is at the moment an outlier
yeah very much so I mean the way
protection is delivered here in the UK
by the police service is vastly
different to presidential style security
so you know the the large Grand closures
of roads and lots of police officers is
something that we always used to try and
avoid you know you want to try and be
um as flexible in your movements as
possible but because it was a a
pre-planned event then you're going to
have some of that process part there and
you're certainly going to see a
protected Convoy with motorcycle
outriders you know certainly moving you
away from Europe from that particular
event and getting you to the next venue
so you would have seen things
um slightly different slightly more
structured so therefore when you when
you take that away and like you said
Prince Harry now being in the private
sector working with a private security
team then that that is going to look far
different because they're not going to
be able to tap into those resources but
nonetheless in the private sector we
always look to work with law enforcement
you know and just get a handle on on
that event and even if it's going to be
a case of look we're having problems is
there a number that we can dial into
um because then you know law enforcement
do have a responsibility a duty of care
as an ordinary citizen not just
um as a prince of this country but as an
ordinary citizen to to support them if
they feel that their life is under
threat from whatever the circumstances
and certainly when you look at this you
know yes there could be no threat to
life purely because of the the driving
the difficulty the driver may have had
and obviously if this is a a New York
Taxi Driver then you certainly must
probably not used to that level of
intrusion and difficulty with his driver
in terms of Life as a royal Protection
Officer I would imagine when you take on
that role
your first mission is to protect the
Royals from harm people who set out to
physically harm them this whole
Paparazzi game
is a whole other area isn't it in terms
of
they're not intent on harm but you know
the side product of what they are doing
can cause harm can you give me an idea
of what it's like to be protecting
somebody who is surrounded by Vehicles
you know I've got visions of you know
cars running red lights
driving while taking pictures trying to
block your car to stop it so they can
take pictures can you give me an idea of
what that's like not just for you know
say that you can Duchess of Sussex
involved but for the team around them
trying to protect them
it is it is an extremely difficult
scenario and you know I always say that
we we if we don't learn from history
then we're failing to learn so you know
you've got to put these these
mitigations in place you know but you
you can't also get get sidetracked you
know this individual is going to take a
photograph of you
um well there are other people that are
out there that wishing to do you harm
but it's actually the whole
circumstances and it is the
circumstances that you have described
whereby people are blocking your car in
people are trying to take photos
pursuing you on bikes they are jumping
red lights they are driving across the
Pavements to get that picture and
therefore it becomes not just a safety
issue for your principal but it also
becomes a public safety issue because
the fact the very fact that you're there
is now creating this very difficult
Public Safety environment and like I
said we you know we have to look back at
history and we know that
um the tragedy that unfolded in Paris
was because of those very actions
Simon thank you very much indeed Simon
Morgan former Royal Protection Officer
there just talking us through you know
some of the circumstances that are
involved in protecting Royals and other
high-profile individuals particularly
where Paparazzi are involved Simon thank
you very much for your Insight just want
to run you through what we know so far
this afternoon with regard to this
breaking news
um Harry and Megan involved in a
Paparazzi Chase last night in New York a
statement from Prince Harry's
spokesperson says last night the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex and Ms Ragland
were involved in a near catastrophic car
chase at the hands of a ring of Highly
aggressive Paparazzi this Relentless
Pursuit lasting over two hours resulted
in multiple near collisions involving
other drivers on the road pedestrians
and two NYPD officers while being a
public figure comes with a level of
interest from the public it should never
come at the cost of anyone's safety
dissemination of these images given the
ways in which they were obtained
encourages a highly intrusive practice
that is dangerous to all involved
uh well let's just bring you uh pictures
we have of the events and that's the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex along with
her mother who is there on the left of
the picture Doria Ragland it was a red
carpet event a Gala in New York where
the Duchess of Sussex was picking up an
award in New York these are pictures we
have of them arriving at the event just
to warn you that the next set of
pictures we're going to show you
involve flash photography
so this is the event
um as you can see so much attention on
the couple uh that's because it's the
first public appearance of Harry and
Megan since Prince Harry's autobiography
was published that seems like a long
time ago now and of course since the
king's coronation uh Megan uh picking up
an award at the foundation for women's
annual Gala it recognized her Global
advocacy to empower and Advocate on
behalf of women and girls well let's
cross live now to our U.S correspondent
James Matthews
um James I've just brought our viewers
the statement once again it is very
short on detail but it very much
underlines the seriousness of the
situation the sussexes felt they were in
last night
yeah that's certainly their view they
think that there was Reckless endangered
endangerment over a period of some two
hours this event uh Jane was taking
place in the Ziegfeld Ballroom that's
Midtown Manhattan very busy area just a
block and a bit away from Trump Tower so
talk about to our Chase
um that would tally with a trip to and
from the airport perhaps although they
were my understanding is they were
staying at a private uh residence so
quite where their Journey started and
ended we're not entirely sure in terms
of what was going on during this Pursuit
by Paparazzi
I'm like to believe or we're allowed to
believe that it involved around six half
a dozen Vehicles blacked out and there's
no doubt in the Harry and Megan party
that their Convoy was being endangered
by Behavior which included going the
wrong way down the wrong way a one-way
Street running red lights
I suppose typical Paparazzi Pursuits
speaking on the phone while driving
taking pictures whilst on the move I
would like to believe that the NYPD did
at some point step in but that didn't
appear to stop the pursuit of Paparazzi
there is it's our understanding there is
footage that was taken by Harry and
Megan's security of what went on it will
be interesting to see that and that will
reflect a reality of what went on or
certainly provide confirmation of what
is being claimed at this stage
um because you know this happened over
something like two hours we're told
there would have been a lot of people a
lot of cameras a lot of participants in
that very case
all of whom we have yet to hear from so
that kind of confirmation
would reinforce the claims that are
being made bearing in mind the the
cynicism generally that surrounds Harry
and Megan uh that will feed into this
story and are ballast to what we're
being told in that statement which talks
about reckless endangerment and the
pursuit of Harry and Megan through the
streets of Manhattan
so you know we are no further forward in
terms of the hard evidence to to
buttress those claims until we get more
from the Harry and Megan camp but they
are in no doubt that people were in
danger that they were endangered by a
Pursuit by Paparazzi in New York last
night
it's just gone four o'clock we're
talking about the breaking news this
afternoon that Prince Harry his wife
Megan and her mother have been involved
in what Harry's spokesperson has called
a near catastrophic car chase involving
Paparazzi just to warn you that there
are flashing images in the footage we
are about to bring you now we understand
that the incident happened after the
couple attended an award ceremony in New
York last night their first public
appearance together since the king's
coronation
or Prince Harry's spokesperson said in a
statement last night the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex and Mrs Ragland were
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase at the hands of a ring of Highly
aggressive Paparazzi this Relentless
Pursuit lasting over two hours resulted
in multiple near collisions involving
other drivers on the road pedestrians
and two NYPD officers
while being a public figure comes with a
level of interest from the public it
should never come at the cost of
anyone's safety dissemination of these
images given the ways in which they were
obtained encourages a highly intrusive
practice that is dangerous to all
involved
well let's bring in our correspondent
Ashner huronag who is following this
story uh from The Newsroom for us
um Ashna short on detail
um but it really does underline the
seriousness of the situation the
sussexes felt they were in last night
yeah an incredible amount of danger it
sounds like too I mean the Relentless
Pursuit line speaks to that Relentless
pressure that there is to see Harry and
Megan photographs of them at any
particular event we have heard in the
last few minutes Sarah Jane from Omid
scoby who's tweeted
um the couples how they are essentially
he is the a biographer and author that
has written the book on Harry and Megan
called finding Freedom a couple of years
ago he has attributed this to a source
close to the sussexes he has said that
Harry Megan and Doria that's Megan's
mother are understandably shaken but
thankful everyone is safe the three of
them had been attending this Gala in
Manhattan this was the woman a vision
award and Megan was picking up one of
those Awards last night she also gave a
speech on stage she'd been encouraging
women to fight for equality as she
accepted this award there had been
photographs of them that were taken as
they arrived for that ceremony and also
once they'd left through the front door
once again and got into those vehicles
and it's understood that they were then
as this statement says relentlessly
pursued in what the spokesperson for the
couple says was a near catastrophic car
chase involving Paparazzi the exact
number of vehicles involved in this
Pursuit is unknown but we understand
that around half a dozen were involved
in following this couple and you've got
a sense there from The Flash photography
of the couple walking into those up
going back down the red carpet into
those vehicles at the street the Ripple
of flashes that followed them it gives
gives you a sense of perhaps what they
have may have experienced on their
Journey
back from that Gala last night this was
Megan's first public appearance for a
while and you know there is that huge
interest in both of them and they
acknowledge
um the couple that there is this
heightened level of tension on both of
them when they do attend these public
events but no I mean any any person
would acknowledge the fact that these
photos should never come at a price of
someone's safety something which is
acknowledged in that statement that they
have released as you say is short but is
powerful nonetheless because it gives
such scant detail but quite shocking
detail to people that are reading it
this morning the couple we understand
may have spent the night in New York but
then perhaps are waking up this morning
in in California and as I say the
biographer of Megan and Harry Omid scoby
who has written a book called Finding a
freedom on a couple has said that a
source close to the sussexes so was
close to Megan and Harry and also
Megan's mother who was with them last
night says they are understandably
shaken but thankful everyone is safe
let's bring in our U.S correspondent
James Matthews who's following the story
of from the U.S uh the pictures you see
on your screen right now are from the
gala attended by the couple last night
along with Megan's mother Doria Raglan
the tree had been at The Miz foundation
for women's 50th anniversary gala which
honors game-changing uh and Visionary
leaders
um Megan was picking up an award she
received the women of visionable
recognizing her Global advocacy to
empower and Advocate on behalf of women
and girls
um James just looking at these happy
pictures here of the couple uh the night
obviously
didn't end with such big smiles by the
sounds of it because they went through
what is being described by Prince
Harry's spokesperson as quietly ordeal
it lasted two and a half hours and I
must admit as I was reading out the
statement live on air people were
getting in touch fearing the worst
because of course there are such Echoes
of Prince Harry's mother and what
happened to her in 1997.
yes yeah and many of us remember where
we were on that night in 1997. uh Sarah
Jane I was walking in the middle of the
night and in Balmoral when you'll
remember William and Harry as young
children uh came out walked along the
line of flowers tributes to their
mothers two of them really barely looked
like they knew what was going on Ashen
faced
um confronting or facing a nation in the
days after they had lost their nearest
and dearest so that was a shocking event
a shocking Pursuit through the streets
of Paris and a moment of Shame for all
concerned and of course that then lie
the roots of Harry's hatred resentment
anger towards the media that he believes
cost him and his family their mother
he's carried that through life and
that's been laid bare by him publicly on
a number of occasions so when we hear
about a Pursuit recklessness potentially
Castro catastrophic words like that used
by his spokesman in relation to a car
chase through the busy streets of New
York then you know one does feel
concerned one feels sympathy and an
empathy with him for that kind of
situation I think given Harry and
Megan's history and their public profile
I think it will be useful to to bolster
The credibility of what we're hearing in
the statement from his spokesperson and
there's every indication that we will
get additional evidence to to buttress
the claims that we are being told about
uh because we're told there is evidence
it was taken by their security of what
was going on over the course of two
hours and more in this allowed just car
chase my understanding is that there
were around half a dozen blacked out
Vehicles involved in this and the
information we have about their behavior
relates to you know breaking traffic
rules going the one the wrong way up a
one-way Street running a red light
speaking on the phone taking pictures
whilst on the move so it was clearly uh
not ideal and it was if that is the case
it was unsafe and unacceptable
New York is a busy place there is a lot
of bad driving that goes on in New York
I think what Harry and Megan and their
spokespeople
who work with the media and know how the
media works and know the layer of
cynicism that surrounds Harry and Megan
in the UK perhaps more than elsewhere
they will know the importance of being
able to add credibility to these claims
so that the public at large can make a
judgment on what it's like potential
catastrophe recklessness Relentless
Pursuit so that the public at large can
make a judgment and assessment of how
much danger was posed to Harry and Megan
themselves and to others on the streets
of New York my understanding is that at
some point NYPD officers did step in to
try to to provide some kind of obstacle
to those that were in Pursuit but that
didn't
stop them chasing the picture of Harry
and Megan so they say they were
personally endangered that would be a
question that
that to which there is no
credible or to which there is not an
answer that is backed up by the evidence
at this stage perhaps the footage filmed
by their security will give us a sense
of how much they were personally
impacted by this car chase you know how
much was it about driving it's stupid
Relentless unacceptable driving by
people chasing them how much and to what
extent were they personally endangered
that's that's what the message we're
getting very clearly by a spokesperson
for Harry and Megan uh one imagines that
and due course given that they do have
evidence that's my understanding one of
margins will see that evidence but
there's no question that they were
clearly shaken up by this it's something
they are particularly sensitive to given
the history given Princess Diana Paris
the car crash the fatal car crash we saw
evidence of their anxiety in this kind
of situation in their Netflix
documentary didn't we when there was a
camera inside a vehicle it was in the UK
as I recall it was from the airport to
to somewhere else and
they were anxious Megan was particularly
anxious about a Paparazzi or a camera
that they had spotted and that seemed to
be in Pursuit we didn't see the camera
but we saw how they reacted to being
pursued being chased by the media they
are particularly sensitive to the media
I might say they're well able to handle
the media in controlled situations they
were in the Zeke felt Ballroom in
Midtown Manhattan last night just around
the corner from Trump Tower not far from
the Hilton and Midtown Manhattan I was
there last December where when they were
being lauded by a particular
organization Harry was given giving a
speech and it was a red carpet event
there was no sign
of them going inside of course you go to
these events and the media and we're no
exception we want pictures of them so
camera outside the building waiting for
their arrival camera inside looking for
them inside hoping to to grab a few
words with them in that situation last
December there was no there was no sign
of them outside the building they were
taken in a a side door all very private
away from the the eyes of the paparazzi
it's the paparazzi who tend to be
lurking at the doors of these Hotel
buildings because what happens is that
you have accredited media so last night
in the Ziegfeld Ballroom there would
have been accredited media lining up by
the red carpet ready for controlled
pictures of Harry and Megan which is
fine that makes their money they can
sell these pictures uh the paparazzi who
are not accredited often freelance
photographers nothing wrong with that I
mean they're still you know still
photographers very much masters of their
trade but their trade without
accreditation is waiting at the door to
because they they've not been accredited
by the organizers their picture has to
come outside the building so they're
looking for arrival shots Harry and
Megan on the Move shots and they much of
the time actually are the more lucrative
images because
they are an uncontrolled situations they
are caught off guard and that as an
image uh can be more striking it can be
the image that fits better onto a
magazine or newspaper front page
therefore it earns more money for the
photographer uh concerned and for the
publication that carries the image so
that's the way it works Harry and Megan
there is to a large degree an avoidance
of media with controlled situations once
they're inside when I saw them last
December on the red carpet they were
very much in control of their
environment Harry looking very relaxed
and in front of a very loud
quite aggressive press mob and that's
the accredited media inside this
controlled situation it was in the wake
of a big news event related to his
family so there was a question to be
asked and an answer perhaps to be
delivered by him he knew that and it was
a loud press but he seemed quite capable
of managing uh the media at that
particular time and I was in a crowd of
something like 30 odd media and he has
aided of course by and he and she are
aided by organizers and their own
security protection in these buildings
you know it is when they get out when
they're on their way and when they're up
when they're on their way in and when
they are on their way out that is when
uh the private security and everyone
around them and they themselves don't
have the same kind of control that
environment New York City a busy Place
busy roads unless you close off these
roads you know you wait at traffic
lights you jockey for a position along
with everybody else in the streets of
New York and the ruins of New York are
you know Pretty Reckless and dangerous
at the best of times with half a dozen
blacked out vehicles in Pursuits and
that then pursue that clearly would have
increased the kind of danger and sense
of
of anxiety let me just tell you
something that we are being told Sarah
Jane TMZ as they call themselves here
are
um they're saying this and use
organization at some point during the
chase an SUV pulled over and the trio
jumped into a New York taxi and beat a
hasty Retreat it looks like the police
tried to outwit The Paparazzi by driving
in a different direction than the taxi
so that's interesting that's TMZ are
saying that at some point during
during this chase the SUV big vehicle in
which they were Harry Megan and Megan's
mum TMZ are saying that it pulled over
and the three of them jumped into a taxi
and beat a haste of a trade it looks
like TMZ are saying that having jumped
in the taxi that went one way and the
Convoy went the other a common tactic
used by uh the authorities and security
to try to to give the media I'll give
the paparazzi the slip in New York
so
um that's interesting the telegrapher
reporting daily trailer off they're
reporting that the trio took refuge in a
police station to change taxes that uh
that's what the telegraph was saying and
that that's interesting when I read
about the first thing about the taxi the
question is well how did they get a taxi
without the paparazzi seeing that
they've gone into a taxi and chasing
that taxi according to the telegraph
they took Refuge at a police station
unseen away from the eyes of the
paparazzi and then that taxi would have
left leaving the paparazzi chasing a
convoy without Harry Megan and Megan's
mum so that's these are early reports
it's all very early it was only
something like 45 minutes ago that Harry
and Megan's
spokesperson put out this statement Jane
So gradually we are putting together the
pieces of the jigsaw and there are many
pieces yet to be put in place pieces of
the jigsaw that will be in the
possession of many people because this
was two hours there were Paparazzi
involved there were cameras involved
there was it was mypd involved and there
were members of the public involved we
are led to believe that security footage
was being taken by Harry and Megan's
security details so all these
individuals have the opportunity to
provide their first hand eyewitness
evidence to what went on and one
imagines that from many if not most we
will get that and the question will be
how does Harry and Megan's story
tally with the story of others who were
watching on that is of interest because
it's of interest in the story of Harry
and Megan a story that is surrounded by
cynicism let's let's be honest about it
and there will be many saying well okay
you're saying X let's see the evidence
to back up your story and people will be
pointing I suppose to a court case that
took place on a court hearing with two
place not a couple of days ago in the UK
courts Harry has taken the home office
to court the home office you'll remember
is not allowing him police protection
the ability to buy police protection
when he comes to the UK he's not happy
about that to the extent he's gone to
court to try to overturn that he's
appealing against that he wants the
ability to pay for police security of
whilst in the UK so that's where we are
at the moment uh Sarah Jane no response
from the NYPD they're saying nothing
officially on the matter at all nothing
to them report by the telegraph that
during the chase the three of them
sought refuge in a police station to
change into a taxi and so the
telegrapher saying TMZ are saying that
they jumped out of the vehicle they were
in
to get into a taxi and give the
paparazzi
the slip
James thank you that ties into what
we've been seeing we have got moving
footage of the the couple leaving that
guy in New York last night and getting
into a a big black four-wheel drive and
then obviously there are pictures
circulating on social media of them in a
New York Taxi a lot of eyebrows raised
as to why they at Earth would have got
into uh a taxi in New York but that may
well explain how the evening unfolded
for the Duke and Duchess of Sussex let's
just remind you of the statement we had
in earlier this afternoon a Prince
Harry's spokesperson saying last night
that you can Duchess of Sussex and Miss
Ragland and that's Megan's mother were
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase at the hands of a ring of Highly
aggressive Paparazzi this Relentless
Pursuit lasting over two hours resulted
in multiple near collisions involving
other drivers on the road pedestrians
and two NYPD officers while being a
public figure comes with a level of
interest from the public it should never
come at the cost of anyone's safety
dissemination of these images given the
way in which they were obtained
encourages a highly intrusive practice
that is dangerous to all involved
uh well this is how yesterday evening
started for the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex and Doria Ragland Megan's mother
red carpet event uh a Gala in New York
Megan being given an award this is
pictures of the couple arriving at that
event
this is the couple leaving that event
and it was as they were leaving that
this two and a half hour as we've been
told
Pursuit started just to let you know
that the next batch of images we're
going to bring you do contain flash
photography so just to warn you about
that
this is the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
leaving you can just see the level of
press attention as James Matthews was
saying there is accredited media inside
that Gala to take those official photos
in the red carpet but then of course
Paparazzi outside the event waiting for
those unofficial photos of the couple
and it's understood that those
paparazzis continued to follow the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex as they left the
event
for joining us now Dr Tessa Dunlop Royal
historian and author of Elizabeth and
Philip a really good of you to join us
this afternoon to react to this story
first of all your initial thoughts when
you heard this breaking news a little
earlier
it's extraordinary
sort of immediate emotional U-turn one
minute you're looking at Exquisite
photographs of a woman in Vision award a
beautiful gold dress Doria Ragland
looking Exquisite also age 67 and
feeling slightly joyous for the couple
it's not been an easy ride and there
they are putting on a show in New York
and then suddenly this grotesque really
echoed to the Past uh Harry's mother in
1997 How can any of us ever forget uh uh
came to a sticky demise um with
Paparazzi in pursuit of her vehicle
understandably we haven't had the
sources verified we don't know or
haven't had details confirmed of exactly
what happened uh NYPD uh were involved
um it sounds
deeply unpleasant and I'm sure for Harry
involved in it was a massive trigger uh
we know from his book you know he went
to visit the said tunnel where his
mother lost his life in in 2007 and um
this will be renderland of uh really the
most formative and gruesome period in
his childhood and I think it's
understandable you know I know already
I've heard other channels question oh
can you really have a you know car chase
in New York for that long I'm I'm
absolutely sure that no matter how long
the car chase was for it felt far too
long
um uh from the point of view of the
prince with the woman or the two women
who he loves dearly in the vehicle with
him so I have great sympathy with them
and it seems a terrible way to end a
rather successful night
um you'll have heard the statement it is
short but it is very to the point and
reading between the lines there is no
doubt in the Duke and duchess's Minds
that you know near catastrophic they
believe that it could have been fatal
any Collision
has the potential to be fatal uh cars
are fatal always one potentially
um and uh I think that it's a Salient
reminder
that and Harry will have been very aware
of this and I'm sure it's one of the
reasons why um he's taking the case
um against uh Britain's home office and
his own security over here that he is
always going to be a target of interest
between the two of them they're far
greater than the sum of their parts and
they're tracked staggering quantities of
column inches SJ you and I you know on
the front line of Journalism know that
and it people could say oh well look
they fueled it you know they've written
their Memoir they've done their uh their
Netflix well so be it I've written A
Memoir of sorts we are daily in public
view but we don't expect to be chased uh
to the point of Collision in in a city
in America I don't think that one should
ever equal the other and um I I think
there is a case in point here about
treatment of public figures and the line
between what is and what isn't
acceptable in the way in which we report
them it's also a reminder that as the
celebrity no matter how much you try and
curate your story and control it
yourself once you're in the public
domain you're never fully in control
and they reference that in their
statement don't they they reference the
way in which these images were obtained
and how it is you know very intrusive
and the message in that is that this
should not be happening
I'm interested in what you said there
about
um celebrities and high profile figures
because
you know this kind of Paparazzi interest
in the Royals
is a new thing I mean you think about
the paparazzi in America and you think
of you know we've all seen those images
particularly replayed in recent years of
Britney Spears and the likes you know
being chased around the Hollywood Hills
by cars put in dangerous situations to
get that unguarded photograph
and it's since the Diana era that this
has turned onto the Royals I think
that's fair to say
yeah I mean some might call it the
celebratization of the Royals the
difference was there was a pact if you
like between the fourth estate and the
royal family you see in the last 100 150
years they've become our first family
that that become popular monarchy rather
than political monarchy and that
requires a relationship with the Press
because one fuels the other but I mean
even in the Queen's Young Life there
were times when there was a feeling that
the Press had overstepped the mark for
instance in the coverage of her um
honeymoon down in Broadlands a state
where they sort of people crashed into
the um Cathedral or the Abbey where they
were where they were enjoying a service
and they felt hounded but of course
every time the the media kind of steps
it up again we don't just have 24 7
media now we have 24 7 social media
everyone is curating their own
narratives in a sense it's it's become
impossible to avoid it and so therefore
the idea that you have people born into
a goldfish Bowl which is what Harry was
and people might say well he's he's lent
into that but yeah but that was his
training his life's training was to be a
prince a public figure so he's lent into
that training but actually there are no
boundaries now and previously there were
boundaries between what the Press had
access to and what the private royal
family were allowed to consider their
own narrative and I think that's become
very blurred and it's also a bit like
whack-a-mole okay let's have after Diana
or something an incident happens let's
you know review the way the Press
behaves in Britain but of course this is
a global story they are Global
personalities and the British press
doesn't incidentally just Source its
stories from Britain we know that I mean
who which Paparazzi and which agencies
were they feeding those men and women
who were pursuing the couple if indeed
they were last night
you say it's an impossible situation you
know Prince Harry has been very public
in fighting for
you know
tackling unlawful and intrusive
practices by the Press he is very vocal
about that he's actually in the high
court
fighting it at the moment I was just
interesting interested in using the word
impossible there you know is this
something that won't change I mean every
time we talk about an incident involving
an intrusion of the press that ruins a
life
can sometimes be fatal we talk about a
line being drawn that's it things have
to get better
and you know just looking at what's
unfolding this afternoon you wonder if
that will ever be the case
I mean
you make a very good point and
um it's interesting I and curated what I
was going to say that was a spontaneous
use of the word impossible but it does
feel a bit like a double bind but on the
one hand it's his Crusade against the
perhaps quote unquote this is his
lifetime's work or one of them he's
decided to take on malpractice you're
right he's in the court at the moment
against mg M group and of course we know
there are other big names besides them
but but the point is that it's it's a
multi-million dollar Global industry so
and and this goes beyond National
borders so you can fight one group in
one country but elsewhere The Narrative
unfolds in a different fashion and of
course they all overlap and what is
incidentally formal old-school press as
you and I would refer to and what is
social media websites blogging YouTube
people uploading on Tick Tock you know
where does that boundary lie today it's
so much harder to control it so so
actually the Juggernaut that is The
Duchess the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
and people Lampoon them I think often
they get kind of beaten with the Stick
of oh you know that after the money that
they're in for the big dollar well they
need it if they are also having to make
sure and guarantee their own security
and last night is evidence of that and
it's I think it's understandable why a
man of Harry's standing Born Into the
weird world that he was born into
actually feels that really in many ways
should be his Birthright to to have that
security whenever he comes back to
Britain and you can see why he's clearly
missing it in America isn't he at the
moment being a celebrity of that
standing but you know the combination of
Hollywood tinsel and old school British
royalty it's proved that it's got legs
and that will run and run
yeah the public interest in the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex is increasing rather
than decreasing uh whether that is
something they want or something they
don't want that clearly seems to be the
case a Dr Tessa Dunlop uh thank you very
much indeed they're just reacting to
this afternoon's breaking news uh Prince
Harry and his wife Megan The Duchess of
Sussex and Megan's mother involved in an
intense Paparazzi chase after an awards
ceremony in New York last night uh just
to warn you that some of the pictures
we're going to bring you do contain
flash photography uh so just to give you
a heads up on that
but first I'll bring you um the
statement that was released a little
earlier Prince Harry spokesperson saying
last night the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex and Ms Ragland were involved in a
near catastrophic car chase at the hands
of a ring of Highly aggressive Paparazzi
this Relentless Pursuit lasting over two
hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers while being a public figure
comes with a level of public interest
the it should never come at the cost of
anyone's safety dissemination of these
images given the ways in which they were
obtained encourages a highly intrusive
practice that is dangerous to all
involved
over these are pictures of the event
last night
these are taken before the couple left
these are pictures of them leaving and
it's after this departure from the hotel
in New York that we understand
the chase by Paparazzi began just to
warn you this is The Flash photography
bit
let's bring in our correspondent Ashley
her and actually is following the story
for us in The Newsroom
um let's just pick up on that last line
of the statement dissemination of these
images given the ways in which they were
attained encourages a highly intrusive
practice that is dangerous to all
involved and having said that in the
statement it's interesting that none of
the he's Paparazzi pictures have
appeared anywhere we understand they may
have appeared on a newspaper online site
but were quickly removed this morning
after details of how they were obtained
emerged you get the sense that these
were images that were captured in
extremely dangerous scenario we've got a
little bit more information about
exactly who may have been involved in
this Pursuit Sarah Jane the couple we
understand
um may have been followed by around half
a dozen blacked out Vehicles which were
being driven by unidentified people
within that there was likely that that
sea or that um Ripple of flash
photography that is so common with
events that any Top Class celebrities
attend but let alone Harry and Megan the
vehicles were said to have been driven
on Pavements some may have jumped red
lights and reversed down a one-way
street it's also understood that at
least one of the drivers was using their
phone behind the wheel and at least one
other is said to have been photographing
whilst driving and one of the cars is
also understood may have illegally
blocked a moving vehicle there are some
very very early reports at this stage
it's worth saying that perhaps the
couple and Megan's mother Doria were
forced to change the vehicle they were
traveling in in the last images that we
we have of them up until this alleged
this car chase happened we see them
moving down a red carpet and into a
blacked out vehicle there is some social
media videos that show the couple then
in a taxi perhaps a yellow sort of New
York cab if you will and it's some
suggestion that they may have moved
Vehicles because the intensity of this
um this car chase
um we understand also that they were
hoping to spend the evening at a
friend's house
um this is Harry and Megan and Doria
Megan's mum who was with her at that
event they were meant to spend the night
at a private residence but there is some
suggestion that they didn't want to
compromise that friend's home so
therefore to make some quick changes to
their plans but you're right to pick up
on the the dissemination thought and
whether these images are going to make
it into the public domain there's a
strong suspicion that there's going to
be a clamp down and they absolutely will
not be and this is likely to be the only
images we see of of last night Megan
there picking up an award a woman
Envision award she had given a speech
that night and she'd received this award
at this garland that was taking place in
Midland at Manhattan in New York now
before this Relentless Pursuit as it was
described by their spokesperson there is
some suggestion that there was footage
that was filmed by their private
security team during this car chase
which may
corroborate I suppose the evidence
that's that's in this statement it'll be
interesting to see whether we get sight
of some of that footage that was taken
by their private security team we're
saying that they did have private
security team as we under team with them
as we understand it of course since
leaving their roles as senior Royals
that's something we've had to
financially secure themselves and an
independent
manner but as I say there is this
suggestion about half a dozen Vehicles
were involved in this car chase
yesterday it is worth saying that
according to the couple's bar graph Omid
scoby he has said he is quoted and
attributed this to a source closed
captioning not available
[Music]
is being called into question to what
level is that Pursuit okay it's at this
in this particular instance it sounds
incredibly distressing and Incredibly
intense and it's described as being
relentless and it speaks to the
Relentless pressure of course that
people go to to try and get images of
this couple but it sounds like an
incredibly incredibly terrifying
incident for them for all three of them
to have been involved in
following that story for us this
afternoon the breaking news that the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex and The
Duchess of sussex's mother were involved
in a near catastrophic car chase earlier
on the program I spoke to a former Royal
Protection Officer Simon Morgan
I think it's um an alarming development
from the security perspective and
certainly when we look look back in
history concerning the Duke's mother
then we know the way that that tragedy
unfolded so I think it's most probably
extremely alarming and distressing for
them but I think there's going to have
to be an investigation maybe from NYPD
as to what support mechanisms
um their security team was able to draw
upon when they were there if any
um and you know what a duration of a car
chase of two hours in this scenario just
seems very a very long time with no
intervention at some point to me
you look at a two slightly different
scenarios where that takes place here in
London or indeed uh in the US if you
look at the U.S scenario then you'll be
working in conjunction with the Secret
Service you'd be working in conjunction
with
um NYPD and they would be adding the
support mechanisms to royalty protection
and the officers that are deployed
overseas a lot more recce would be
involved a lot more of the planning
phase but certainly even now in the
private sector where we work we always
look to work hand in glove with law
enforcement because that's something
that we need the support of whether that
be an intelligence piece not necessarily
any form of physical support but
sometimes just a contact number you know
should we have any issues that we need a
law enforcement involvement so it's
something that the security Team No
Doubt will have a look at to see whether
um they got those right but you know as
you alluded to the Duke started his
legal case again against the home office
and the Metropolitan Police Service in
relation to his
PC right that he could possibly buy
metropolitan police officers on the
protection front when he kind of comes
into the UK so it's a it's a rather
timely event that highlights some of the
risks but the way uh protection is
delivered here in the UK by the police
service is vastly different to
presidential style security so you know
the the large Grand closures of roads
and lots of police officers is something
that we always used to try and avoid you
know you want to try and be
um as flexible in your movements as
possible but because it was a a
pre-planned event then you're going to
have some of that process part there and
you're certainly going to see a
protected Convoy with motorcycle
outriders you know certainly moving you
away from your from that particular
event and getting you kind of to the
next venue so you would have seen things
um slightly different slightly more
structured so therefore when you when
you take that away and like you said
Prince Harry now being in the private
sector working with private security
team then that that is going to look far
different because they're not going to
be able to tap into those resources but
nonetheless in the private sector we
always look to work with law enforcement
you know and just get a handle on on
that event and even if it's going to be
a case of look we're having problems is
there a number that we can dial into
because then you know law enforcement do
have a responsibility a duty of care as
an ordinary citizen not just as a prince
of this country but as an ordinary
citizen to to support them if they feel
that their life is under threat from
whatever the circumstances and certainly
when you look at this you know yes there
could be no threat to life purely
because of the the driving the
difficulty the driver may have had and
obviously if this is a a New York Taxi
Driver then you certainly must probably
not used to that level of intrusion and
difficulty with his driver it is an
extremely difficult scenario and you
know I always say that we we if we don't
learn from history then we're failing to
learn so you know you've got to put
these these mitigations in place you
know but you you can't also get get
sidetracked you know this individual is
going to take a photograph of you
um when there are other people that are
out there that wishing to do you harm
but it's actually the whole
circumstances and it is the
circumstances that you have described
whereby people are blocking your car in
people are trying to take photos
pursuing you on bikes they are jumping
red lights they are driving across the
Pavements to get that picture and
therefore it becomes not just a safety
issue for your principal but it also
becomes a public safety issue because
the fact the very fact that you're there
is now creating this very difficult
Public Safety environment and like I
said we you know we have to look back at
history and we know that
um the tragedy that unfolded in Paris
was because of those very actions
foreign
these are pictures of the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex and Megan's mother
Doria Ragland at that event in New York
last night that was a red carpet picture
this is the couple leaving you can see
in the distance there the flash of a
camera just to warn you that these
pictures a lot of flash photography you
can see so many Paparazzi outside that
event in New York to snap the couple as
they leave getting into that big people
carrier or is it four by four I can't
quite tell but it's a big vehicle anyway
we're led to believe that that is the
original vehicle that Paparazzi began to
follow there are them reports we haven't
verified them yet but there are some
reports that the couple took refuge in
and New York police station and it's
from there that they meant then moved
into a new York Taxi the Yellow Taxi
um that there have been pictures of on
social media again this is unverified
but we do know they originally left in a
big blacked out vehicle and that was the
vehicle that was at the start of that
Paparazzi Pursuit let's just recap the
statement we've had it's short but it's
to the point it says last night the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex Amazon were
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase at the hands of a ring of Highly
aggressive Paparazzi this Relentless
Pursuit lasting over two hours resulted
in multiple near collisions involving
other drivers on the road pedestrians
and two NYPD officers while being a
public figure comes with a level of
interest from the public it should never
come at the cost of anyone's safety
dissemination of these images given the
ways in which they were obtained
encourages a highly intrusive practice
that is dangerous to all involved well
let's get reaction from the US and bring
in our U.S correspondent James Matthews
and I think that last line of the
statement James is perhaps telling that
the image is taken in this two-hour
Pursuit none of them have appeared
anywhere
that's right none of them publicly
Synergy and I might say I've had sight
of an image to be verified and it's not
been made public but it is uh Harry or
selling Megan in the back of a yellow
taxi in the front passenger see what
appears to be a security guard and
presumably behind the wheel the taxi
driver wearing glasses looking straight
down the barrel of whichever camera took
that image
it is strikingly similar to a very
famous
and notorious image very famous for the
wrong reasons of Princess Diana through
the windscreen of a taxi in Paris in the
late 90s in the minutes before she died
with only Paul the French driver you
might remember with his glasses looking
at the camera the security guard
trevoris Jones busying himself in the
passenger seat and there in the back
seat uh Princess Diana you can just see
Megan in the back seat of this
particular image and you know one one
doesn't know at this stage whether or
not that will be made public clearly it
is the subject of some considerable
controversy but the parallel between
these two images strip separated by
decades uh go right to the very heart of
the matter don't don't they for the
heart of the matter for Harry and Megan
because that's their anxiety that's
their fear that's their source of a
hatred and resentment towards the media
because Harry waves that the media's
pursuit on that night and around across
our Hall across many years that led to
his mother's death and we've seen
evidence of that we've seen a Netflix
documentaries Harry and Megan in the
back of a vehicle being chased by a
camera we've seen their anxiety their
sensitivity to a media Pursuit on the
move and that's what their spokesman
says that this very much was a media
Pursuit on the move that caused the
danger to life that created the
potential for catastrophe
um details that we are learning as as
thing you know as elements come to light
are surround the the driving concerned
surround what they thought put wives in
danger and that kind of driving is
things like going the wrong way down a
one-way Street being on the phone while
on the Move driving on Pavements were
led to believe and it's my understanding
that the NYPD
uniformed officers did step in at points
on this journey at least one point to
try to stop the pursuit but they were
essentially ignored and the pursuit
continued that's our understanding and
at this stage we're only hearing really
from the Harry and Megan Camp the NYPD
have yet to see anything publicly as
have members of the so-called Paparazzi
who were involved in this Chase were
it's my understanding that they were in
blacked out Vehicles that's a
description that's come to us that were
around half a dozen of them and were led
to believe that footage exists of at
least part of this car chase which
lasted something like two hours and more
how Harry and Megan flew in from
California prior to that occasion a very
happy occasion at the Zeke felt Ballroom
in Midtown Manhattan she was awarded for
her contribution to gender equality
among other things so she was being
celebrated in the company of many people
inside that venue and of course her
mother was there she and Harry were side
by side on the red carpet and it was
when they left of course that this
particular situation
ensued I'm just uh I'm just looking at
my phone crj news is coming in all the
time and let me read you the something
that's come to us from two senior law
enforcement sources and I'm reading this
fresh
when they were leaving the Zeke field
Ziegfeld theater Harry and Megan had
private security with them they wanted
to go back to where they were staying on
the Upper East Side they were staying or
the plan was to stay at the private
residence of an associate a lot of
Paparazzi were at the Ziegfeld and the
members of the press didn't know where
they were staying so photographers
wanted to follow them Harry and Megan
didn't want Paparazzi to know where they
were going
so they were driven across 57th Street
up and down the uh Franklin the FDR
Drive
and other streets for a boat an hour and
15 minutes one NYPD vehicle was
escorting their vehicle
the drove to the 19th Precinct in New
York they stayed there for around 15
minutes 19th Precinct I think that to be
a police station
police helped the pair get off the block
they got into a different car
and they got to the residence without
being followed
the officials these law enforcement
officials are saying it was a bit of a
chaotic
scene but they do stress that that
detail that I've just given you is
preliminary on their part as the
official timeline is still being put
together these two sim to officials say
they do not believe that it was quotes
near catastrophic that's what Harry and
Megan's spokesperson had alluded to
uh so that's that's the view of law
enforcement officials who who were there
and who were on the ground they don't
believe it was near catastrophic Harry
and Megan were being escorted by an NYPD
vehicle there appeared to be some degree
of Cat and Mouse
um you know that business of them being
driven across 57th Street up and down
the FDR Drive and other streets for our
boat an hour and 15 minutes the question
will be was that purely to draw it to
throw the paparazzi off their tail so
that the paparazzi wouldn't find out
where they were living maybe that shed
some light on why this lasted for so
long something like two hours or more
that's been a question if they were
staying in New York at the home of a
friend presumably relatively nearby why
did it last so long was it because there
was so long spent trying to throw the
paper Nazi of their till and you know
the paparazzi would have wanted to know
where they were living because
uh that's the way the paparazzi operate
I mean you know we call them paparazzi
there are experienced photographers who
who for whom this is their job uh
masters of their craft their job to find
out where Harry and Megan are living
overnight in New York out of town and
there would be a monetary value on
pictures perhaps in that property in and
around that property what are they
staying with somebody famous you know
that would have been why the paparazzi
were tailing them did want to know where
they were going to be spending the night
clearly Harry and Megan didn't want to
play that game they wanted a degree of
privacy it has been quite the week for
them very much up and down the
glittering spectacle of the two of them
and Megan receiving this award in the
Ziegfeld Ballroom that chase which they
are clearly very unhappy about in
Montecito in California where they live
their permanent residents in the early
hours of Monday morning an arrest was
made at the Gate of that residence
because a stock had turned up and uh he
has since been released on uh on bond so
you know there are many people who want
a part of Harry and Megan's life they
are prepared to go to some lengths to
get that part and it clearly doesn't
square with Harry and Megan's interests
as they would see it
okay James Matthews there with the
latest from the US on the breaking news
this afternoon a couple of interesting
bits of detail uh James brought us there
being attributed uh to NBC their sources
to senior law enforcement sources who
said that the reason uh that this
um incident lasted for nearly two hours
because uh the Duke and Justice of
Sussex seemingly wanted to shake off
Paparazzi because they didn't want them
to know where they were staying in New
York so that could be why it took two
hours for this incident to run its
course another interesting bit of
information was that the two officials
say they do not believe it was near
catastrophic which is of course the key
line at the start of that statement from
the Duke and Duchess of stop Sussex they
said that it was a near catastrophic
event let's bring you that statement in
full last night the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex Emma's Ragland were involved in a
near catastrophic car chase at the hands
of a ring of Highly aggressive Paparazzi
this Relentless Pursuit lasting over two
hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers while being a public figure
comes with a level of interest from the
public it should never come at the cost
of anyone's safety dissemination of
these images given the way in which they
were obtained encourages a highly
intrusive practice that is dangerous to
all so this happening after the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex and Megan's mother
left an event in New York last night the
couple saying it lasted over two hours
and was near catastrophic as we've just
been hearing in the last few minutes
sources telling NBC in America Two
senior law enforcement sources
saying that they do not believe what
they witnessed was near catastrophic
they said that it was a bit of a chaotic
scene but they do not believe it was
near catastrophic officials say that an
official timeline is being put together
NYPD haven't yet commented uh we'll have
more coming up for you in the NewsHour
next
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
It's Five O'Clock you're watching the
NewsHour I'm Jane secker coming up in
the next 60 Minutes Prince Harry and
Megan involved in a near catastrophic
two-hour long car chase involving
Paparazzi according to the prince's
spokesperson
two of the world's leading car
manufacturers call for brexit trading
rules to be renegotiated as the labor
leader says his party would seek a
better deal with the EU
the boss of the collapsed firm British
Vault tells Sky News the UK has missed
its chance to build a battery industry
and the government is to blame
climate scientists warn global
temperatures will pass a key climate
threshold possibly as early as this year
the growing demand for a price cap on
baby formula after Sky News revealed
some parents were stealing to feed their
children
and a major shake-up of home rental
rules that could see no fault evictions
scrapped in England
foreign
[Music]
Prince Harry and his wife Megan have
been involved in what Harry's
spokesperson has called a near
catastrophic car chase involving
Paparazzi a warning that there are
flashing images in the footage that
we're about to show the incident
happened after the couple attended an
awards ceremony in New York last night
their first public appearance together
since the king's coronation the Duke's
team say that the duchess's mum was also
involved in the car chase lasting more
than two hours
well in their statement they say last
night the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and
Ms Ragland were involved in a
near-catastrophic car chase at the hands
of a ring of Highly aggressive paparazzi
this Relentless Pursuit lasting over two
hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road
pedestrians and two NYPD officers
that go on while being a public figure
comes with a level of interest from the
public it should never come at the cost
of anyone's safety dissemination of
these images given the ways in which
they were obtained encourages a highly
intrusive practice that is dangerous to
all involved
but tonight U.S law enforcement sources
are playing down the seriousness of the
incident let's bring in our U.S
correspondent James Matthews James
reports of illegal behavior on the roads
the couple taking refuge in a police
station what more do we know
yeah this all happened uh about 9 50
last night 10 p.m Harry and Megan have
been at this woman of vision event at
which she was lauded for her
contribution to Human Rights and gender
equality a red carpet event you know
lots of media there a happy occasion
they were there in the presence of
Megan's mother that was it the the Zeke
felt Ballroom just around the corner
from from Trump Tower and Midtown
Manhattan a very busy place they then
left the building and that's when things
happened and there is I might say two
sides to the story emerging as to to
what unfolded after they left that
building over the next couple of hours
we have that statement from Harry and
Megan's spokesperson talking about a
near catastrophic event talking about
Paparazzi in Pursuit that endangered
Harry Megan and her mother people inside
their vehicle and everybody else my
understanding is that that related to
something like half a dozen blacked out
Paparazzi Vehicles which uh were
committing a number of traffic offenses
going the wrong way on a one-way Street
driving on the pavement taking pictures
on the Move using the mobile phone on
the move and the world from Harry and
Megan's people is that that put
everybody in danger now in the last few
minutes we've had
guidance reportable guidance from two
senior law enforcement officials in New
York that's come to us from our sister
organization NBC here in the United
States and I'll read you some of what
they have to say because it is not
Square uh with the version First put out
by Harry and Megan it does flesh out
detail but their conclusion is different
they speak about how they left the Zeke
felt uh Ballroom Harry and Megan had
private security with them they wanted
to go back to where they were staying on
the Upper East Side now Harry and Megan
had made arrangements to stay at the
private residence of a friend a lot of
Paparazzi were at the Ziegfeld according
to these officials members of the press
didn't know what Harry and Megan were
staying so the photographers wanted to
follow them Harry and Megan didn't want
Paparazzi to know where they were going
so they were driven across 57th Street
in Manhattan up and down the Franklin D
Roosevelt Drive and other streets for
about an hour and 15 minutes
one NYPD vehicle New York police
department vehicle was escorting theirs
they drove to the 19th Precinct that's a
police station they stayed there around
15 minutes police helped get the pair
off the block they got into a different
car and they got to the residence
without being followed the officials are
describing it as a bit of a chaotic
scene to use their words uh they say
that they do not believe that it was
courts near catastrophic now in terms of
the other vehicle there are pictures uh
not yet published uh they may be
published in due course of Harry and
Megan in a yellow New York Taxi uh now
one image in particular is striking Jane
if anybody remembers the the image
through the windscreen of Princess Diana
in the taxi that crashed causing her
death hungry Paul the driver looking
down the battle of the lens through his
glasses smiling in the passenger seat
the security guard Trevor Reese Jones
busying himself and in the back seat you
catch a glimpse of Diana well there is
at least one image uh which is
strikingly similar driver security guard
and the back seat you can see Megan and
that's the parallel that causes so much
concern isn't it for Harry and Megan
because he is a man who blames the
paparazzi who blames the media blames
their intrusion for causing the death of
his mother I was the 1997 outside bar
model a 12 year old Harry Ashen faced
looking at floral tributes to his mother
from that day he has blamed the media
and Its Behavior for the death of his
nearest and dearest and this clearly
resonates with him so many years on but
as I say there is a disagreement in
terms of the versions of events and just
how dangerous this Paparazzi Pursuit
Lawrence James thank you very much
now two of the world's biggest car
makers have called on the government to
delay the introduction of new
post-brexit trading rules stalantis
which owns Vauxhall Peugeot and Citroen
announced two years ago that it will
make electric vehicles at the Vauxhall
plants in Ellesmere port and Luton now
it says it may not be able to keep that
promise meanwhile the U.S car giant Ford
has echoed those concerns with both
firms calling for post brexit changes
around the sourcing of parts to be
delayed until 2027.
as part of the brexit deal the UK agreed
that 45 of electric vehicle parts must
come from Britain or the EU cars that
don't meet this target will be subject
to 10 tariffs when sold in the EU
stalantis says this tariff makes
production in Japan or South Korea more
competitive the Tariff is due to begin
next year but stalantis and Ford want
the government to agree a delay until
2027 because there aren't enough
electric batteries available in the UK
the labor leader sakir starmer says it
is time to renegotiate the UK's whole
brexit deal
I think there are real improvements to
be made to the EU deal I don't think
many people look at that deal and think
it's working uh very well it was we're
promised to you know an oven ready deal
and we got something which was frankly
Half Baked so there's a lot of work to
do there as there is on everything else
to improve on that clear up the mess and
then power our economy forward because
if there's one thing that has been
significantly bad over the last 13 years
or so it's our growth rate our economy
hasn't grown at the rate that we need it
to grow
a part of the problem is a lack of the
large-scale UK Factory to make the
batteries to Power electric cars the
chancellor told Business Leaders today
that the government is working to
resolve the shortage
and as we move to EVS we need to have
battery making capacity in the UK
we have the ability under the
post-brexit trading arrangements to
import EV batteries from other EU
countries but
the reality is there is a supply
shortage everyone is trying to develop
supply of EV batteries and so we need to
have that Supply here in the UK the
closer it's located to
the factories that are making the rest
of the car the better
and all I would say is watch this space
because we are very focused on making
sure the UK gets that EV manufacturing
capacity
while the Prime Minister has been
reacting to concerns about the effects
of brexit let's go live to Westminster
and our political correspondent Amanda
acass we heard Jeremy Hunt there saying
that things are going to be happening
soon what's he talking about
well we have had it confirmed from
Downing Street this afternoon that the
government is pushing to cut a deal with
the EU over the issue of these tariffs
trying to reduce the kind of Cliff Edge
impact which the car manufacturers are
so worried about the Prime Minister
himself is on the plane on the way to
Japan for the G7
um a pack of traveling reporters are
with Him including our political editor
Beth Rigby and they asked the Prime
Minister what he makes of these concerns
from the car companies about the issue
of brexit these calls to renegotiate the
deal and also broader concerns about the
impact on the economy including Nigel
farage saying he believes that brexit
has been a failure the Prime Minister
hit back at this pretty passionately by
the sounds of things insisting that he
voted for brexit that he believes in
brexit and that as prime minister he
insists he is delivering on the economic
brexit benefits as well he gave a whole
list of what those are including he
claims uh Freeport deregulation of
financial services and also he says
there are plans which we've heard a lot
of talk about recently to reform the
working time directive he insists that
that will save UK businesses billions of
pounds he also talks about reforming and
repealing 2 000 pieces of EU retained
law which is a very delicate matter for
the Prime Minister because when he was
campaigning to be leader of the party he
did actually pledge to scrap or 4 000
pieces of legislation there was a u-turn
on that last week which many of his back
benches are extremely angry about but
the government effectively realized they
didn't have time to deliver that he also
gave a very upbeat narrative on the
economy overall to reporters
um talking about a survey recently
carried out by some 4 000 CEOs who said
the UK was their number one Investment
location in Europe
um the fact that in Japan he's going to
be announcing uh plans for 18 billion
pounds in Investments I think that's
rather optimistic given that we know
from the latest figures that the UK
economy shrank by 0.3 in March and it's
the only one of the G7 which hasn't
recovered it's pre-pandemic level he was
also asked about Liz Trust his trip to
Taiwan which she helpfully made just on
the eve of his trip to the uh to Japan
um that clearly is quite concerning for
Downing Street it's a very delicate part
of the world and it's not necessarily
very helpful to have a former pre- prime
minister freelancing on foreign policy
but he seemed fairly not unconcerned by
that and just reiterated the line that
the UK has a strong alliance with other
countries in its position on Taiwan okay
Amanda thanks very much
well despite the government's assurances
the founder of the battery maker British
Vault has tulskar news that the
government is to blame for the company's
collapse dashing hope of a home-grown
battery Powerhouse speaking publicly for
the first time since the firm went into
Administration oral najari Blaine
British sunak who was Chancellor at the
time for delays in signing off
government grants he's been talking to
Sky Zed Conway who has this report
stuck at number 11. it was Chancellor at
that point right
so so he has to Bear some responsibility
for for what happened if this was a if
this was a timing thing
if you could have got in earlier I think
this would have been different I don't
think I don't think uh Mr shunak
would look at it that way and nor do I
want to point the finger at anybody but
what I do know that there was a main
yeah but it was a major rivalry going on
between Mr Johnson and mrishunak at that
period of time
but that's about if you're looking back
at the one thing that I think British
could have swung it I think British was
collateral damage stuck between a rock
and a hard place between the Rivalry
between 10 and 11. yes
well oral majority was talking to our
economics and data editor at Conway he's
with me now I mean he is laying the
blame pretty squarely at where she's
here next door isn't he very much so I
mean you know some would say well you'd
expect him to do that he was in charge
of this company
um he it's it collapsed it didn't it was
a total disaster and uh he's
understandably might be looking for
scapegoats but the thing is this does
ring true with what a lot of other
people are saying which is that well you
know take a step back one of the big
Stories the big kind of themes within
the economy right now is that we're
shifting towards net zero it's not just
a big environmental story but it's a big
economic story as well because you've
got hundreds if not thousands of
companies who are depending on trying to
build out the infrastructure the
batteries the electric cars the wind
turbines all of that stuff that we're
going to need in the future it's a real
Industrial Revolution and there's a race
on at the moment and America is pushing
really hard throwing lots of money at
their companies Europe the same China
the same as well and the UK feels like
it's kind of potentially in in the rear
of that race at the moment we haven't
yet got a gigafactory as they're called
these just enormous battery factories
and British vaults this company that
that man oral najari was the founder of
was supposed to be the great hope and
yet it does sound like lots of the
efforts to try to get government support
that's that you can see that's the the
site in in the Northeast in Blyth where
they they would have been based a lot of
the efforts to try to get of government
support for it and the government said
they were going to support it then ran
into all of this bureaucracy that is
basically the accusation from from the
head of British well it's worth actually
we can show play just another bit from
the interview where he talks uh about
the government and about their partner
let's just watch that that's
unfortunately didn't see that same
support
from the conservative government in
order to level up the Northeast
because Northeast wasn't as important
for them
as maybe other places in this country
unless UK changes his industrial
strategy
we will keep losing out on large-scale
projects
arrival left
the electric mini left
it's not just British vault
there's a clear lack of industrial
strategy
so that that was that was another uh
clip from oral najari now that as I say
is the kind of message that we're
hearing from quite a lot of people that
whereas around the rest of the world
governments are giving enormous support
to these companies making batteries
making wind turbines whatever it is the
UK has just been much more reticent much
more reluctant to try and provide public
support the government would say well
actually when you look at the example of
what happened with British folds which
is the company that there are
allegations about whether it was very
well run it did eventually go it did
eventually essentially implode it has
now been bought out by an Australian
company but the question marks over what
happens there they'd say well we were
safeguarding public money
you've got to take a risk though a lot
of people would say and the UK so far
has been really reluctant to take take
risks and the result of that is while
other countries around the world are
pushing hard to try and build this
Industrial Revolution the UK really does
look like it's behind and a lot of
people not just their former head of
British fault but many people I talked
to within the industry say
essentially we've squandered a potential
lead we don't have a battery industry
and that's partly because the government
just didn't have the appetite to try and
support companies like this risky as it
would have been good thanks a lot
now campaigners have broadly welcomed
new plans to shake up the rental market
in England the bill will ban no fault
evictions where landlords give no reason
for taking back possession of their
property it'll also make it illegal for
landlords and agents to impose blanket
bans on renting to benefit claimants or
families with children however it would
make it easier for landlords to evict
tenants for anti-social behavior and
missing payments renters will also be
given a legal right to request a pet in
their home which landlords must then
consider and cannot unreasonably refuse
it is certainly the case that we have to
be vigilant about rents everywhere the
good news is that even at a time when
people are facing real pressure on their
household budgets that rents in the
private rented sector have risen less
than inflation and of course in this
legislation we affirm that rents can
only rise once a year and if rents are
thought to be unfair there's an
ombudsman now that we're creating and
ultimately there's the backstop of the
courts and a tribunal in order to ensure
that rents are fixed in a fair market
way
a man has been charged with the murders
of two people whose bodies were found in
a house in Huddersfield on Monday 27
year old Katie Highton and Stephen
Harnett who was 25 are believed to have
been stabbed to death Marcus Osborne
who's 34 has been charged with their
murders and with detaining and
assaulting a second woman against her
will
the defense secretary says that the UK
has no plans to send fighter jets to
Ukraine Ben Wallace was speaking after
meeting his German counterpart in Berlin
they were asked about Ukraine's campaign
to persuade the West to supply it with
F-16 Fighters
our role could only be limited in so far
as training and indeed coordination and
indeed Logistics and you know that's the
limit of her I think it's important to
signal to International Community that
we don't have an objection to people
doing that and and you know remember
people have already put aircraft in you
know we put in helicopters we've donated
seeking helicopters the slovakians have
put in fighter planes they might be
Soviet era but nevertheless they are
fighter planes and Russia doesn't I mean
if you're a Russian infant here I don't
think you really care whether you're
being bombed by a Soviet era plane or a
western plane you just don't want to be
bombed by it
yeah
this weekend's Amelia Romania Grand Prix
in Italy has been canceled because of
severe flooding Formula One teams had
already been warned to stay away from
the track at least five people have been
killed in floods in the region with 5
000 people evacuated F1 officials say
that they've canceled the race to avoid
any extra burden on the Emergency
Services
climate researchers have warned that
it's now more now more likely than not
that global warming will breach a key
temperature limit within the next five
years the World Meteorological
organization says that there's now a 66
chance we will pass the 1.5 degree
global warming threshold by 2027. in
2015 countries agreed to pursue efforts
to limit Global temperature rises to 1.5
degrees under the Paris agreement in
2020 it was predicted there was less
than a 20 chance of breaching 1.5
degrees in the five years ahead while
climate change correspondent Hannah
Thomas Peter has the details the World
Meteorological organization makes
predictions every year on the likelihood
that temperatures will rise Beyond 1.5
degrees above pre-industrial levels in
the following five years and this is the
very first time those scientists have
said that there's a 66 chance so it's
more likely than not that temperatures
will do so they've said it's very
worrying but but potentially temporary
we could bring those temperatures back
down by a sharp reduction in emissions
for example why is this happening
emissions instead of coming down are
going up and with it heat we've seen the
drought droughts for example around the
world in southern us ongoing droughts in
Europe that won't change unless
emissions start falling but it's been
coupled with the emergence of a weather
phenomena climate phenomena called El
Nino which tends to be associated with
warming oceans and with hotter air
temperatures this though is a
tremendously symbolic moment you
mentioned that 1.5 degrees of warming is
a symbolic number around which all the
climate discussions at U.N climate
Summits and Beyond have been orientated
scientists and diplomats and policy
makers know that we're already at 1.2
degrees of warming we don't have very
much time to limit warming to 1.5
degrees and there is real fear amongst
climate diplomats in particular that if
1.5 degrees of warming appears to be
crumbling then this critical shared
consensus will start to ebb away and
Nations will start to reneg on promises
to do their best to limit global warming
this is the NewsHour coming up calls for
a price cap on all infant formula milk
as parents struggle with the cost of
living crisis
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
and now they're going to be arrested we
aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
given day would have been bustling with
people but today it's absolutely
deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
I'm Neville Lazarus and I'm Skye's
reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
parents are calling for the introduction
of a cap on the price of all infant
formula milk it follows the Sky News
investigation which found that some
desperate parents are stealing formula
as they struggle with the cost of living
crisis our national correspondent Tom
parmeter reports
the price Rises have hit hard
some families cannot afford to feed
their babies safely so they're watering
down bottles switching to cow's milk too
early stealing from shops or buying
second-hand tubs online
Kerry's boy Finley is still bottle fed
she's so Furious about what's happening
to families that she's petitioning the
government for change you feel
uncomfortable even walking down the baby
aisle and looking at the baby milk
because the staff instantly think oh
they're going to Nick that it's like
you're treated as a criminal
just because you want to go and buy baby
milk just to help like lower the costs
or provide vouchers for those that work
hard for a living
all of the manufacturers say their
production costs have risen sharply we
went to the only formula milk factory in
Britain kendamill based in Cumbria while
they've raised their prices they
acknowledge their industry needs to do
more for families it's been toughest on
parents it's devastating to see but it
is the result of consistent cost price
inflation led by the multinational
conglomerates that control this Market
how much responsibility should the
industry as a whole take for the
positions that British families are
finding themselves in at the moment we
can't ignore the macroeconomic shocks
that we've had where we would like more
transparency is about the enormous price
discrepancies between very similar baby
formulas on the market do you believe
them the multinationals when they say
that they are doing absolutely
everything they can on behalf of
families
to keep those costs to a minimum I mean
it's
I don't think that they are pricing
those products as cheap as they could
price them for families
Danon who make aptamil and Karen gate so
they are freezing the cost of bigger
value packs Nestle who made the SMA
Brands say they're open to discussing
with government what more they can do
the MP charged with investigating infant
feeding is horrified by what's happening
and is demanding a Government Review I
mean the net effect is a children
growing up
um with you know developmental issues
because they haven't had the proper
nutrition that they've needed as babies
and that's really quick worrying that's
the kind of thing that you see in
countries where there has been you know
famine or malnutrition or war that
should not be happening in the United
Kingdom in 2023 I think it's important
to see if the government could do
something around a ceiling on the cost
of infant formula is a price cap
realistic in what is a commercial Market
well the government allowed this to be a
commercial market and there are times in
the past where the government have set
um limits on on the prices of things
there's no reason why one should cost 10
pounds and one should cost 15 pounds the
UK government continues to say that it
is helping with the cost of living but
because feeding never stops parents who
are in this struggle can't afford to
wait for something to change
Tom Parmenter Sky News
let's go look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
high pressure maintains its influence on
the country over the coming days with
weakening frontal systems attempting to
spread from the Northwest it'll be a
mostly fine evening for England and
Wales with any isolated showers dying
away there'll be more cloud in the north
with rain over Northern Scotland
clearing however low cloud and drizzle
will persist even after the rain is gone
giving Scotland a dull start to Thursday
mostly dry further south but milder than
recent nights away from the southeast
where it may become cold enough for a
few pockets of rural grass Frost
although largely dry it'll be a cloudier
picture tomorrow with weak Sunny spells
it'll still be warm with temperatures
reaching 16 to 19 Celsius for many
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
this is Skye this is the NewsHour coming
up claims of Prince Harry and Megan have
been in a near catastrophic car chase
involving the paparazzi
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
spokesman says the couple have been
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase where we've had response now from
the New York police department they say
that on Wednesday evening last night May
the 16th the NYPD assisted the private
security team protecting the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex there were numerous
photographers that made their transport
challenging that you can just if Sussex
arrived at their destination and there
were no reported collisions summonses
injuries or arrests in regard so that is
from Julian Phillips the Deputy
Commissioner for public information for
NYPD so they're saying no reported
Collision summonses injuries or arrests
and that they got home safely we have
now got a statement also from New York
mayor Eric Adams listen to see what he
has to say you know the Press of
paparazzi's you know they want to get
the right shot they want to get the
right story uh Public Safety must always
be at the Forefront of my The Briefing I
received you know two of our offices
could have been injured New York City is
different
from a small town somewhere you
shouldn't be speeding anywhere but this
is a densely populated city and I think
all of us I don't think there's many of
us who don't recall how
how the his mom died and it would be
horrific to lose the innocent bystander
during a chase like this and something
to have happened to them as well so I
think we have to be extremely
responsible I thought that was a bit
Reckless and irresponsible
well joining us now is Donna Davis the
former head of Scotland yards role
protection command and I get to talk to
you today thank you very much for
joining us can you just give us from
your Insight what kind of protection do
we know that Harry and Megan did have
last night
well I don't know what they have but I
as I understand it they do have former
Metropolitan Police royalty protection
command officers with them uh in the
United States obviously working as
civilians and they are very experienced
by any definition so I I will wait to
hear the truth story as to what really
happened here I don't believe it to our
uh Chase in Manhattan I've worked in
Manhattan you simply couldn't do that
for two hours there so I think we've got
to wait a little while to ensure that
whatever reports are coming out are true
um I'm surprised that some of you know
that they got into a taxi and all that
normally in private security or
otherwise experience I think these
people are they will have a backup plan
Paparazzi are a pain in the backside but
they don't kill you and and decent
normal uh royalty protection officers
know that perfectly well normally you
negotiate if you can if you can't you
use blocking tactics or whatever tactics
are available but what you always have
is a contingency plan or two and I'm
surprised knowing uh the officers uh
ex-officers here and what I suspect is
the truth then I'm surprised that hardly
any of this is true but that's just my
cynical self at the moment we've heard
from some sources when the police saying
that they described as a bit of a
chaotic scene and that the couple were
driving up and down FDR Drive with a
police car escort for quite a long
period of time so rather than being
chased around around the streets they
were sort of hoving to and fro because
they didn't want the paparazzi to follow
them because they were staying at
somebody's private home you can
understand that can't you
well I can to a point but I say again
there are strategies and tactics that
seasoned officers would use and driving
around with allegedly to police cars one
in the front and back is not one that I
would imagine but never say never
um I just find it all quite
extraordinary and I think everyone
should take a deep breath and let's find
out what really happened
it seems that they did go to a police
station and changed Vehicles there that
may have been when they got into the
taxi
um but what do you make of that chain of
events I mean would that be something as
a security officer you would have ever
suggested to somebody that you were
looking after
well as the OSU Commander I didn't
physically do it myself I had teams
actually did it but I have since then
protected some really important people
worldwide
um in a strategic sense so no it's not
something I would contemplate as I say
again I would have a plan a b and c and
depending on the circumstances but the
thought unless is absolutely necessary
of going into a Yellow Cab wouldn't be
something I would normally contemplate
not knowing the facts then I'd have to
wait and see but it's not something I
would contemplate uh doing in any
circumstances unless there was no other
option and what I'm trying to say is you
would have prepared all options if
you're going to a Civic event a
well-publicized event so you would have
Escape Routes you would have considered
a the A to Z of what could go wrong in
these circumstances and surely that that
team know the history around Harry and
his family
okay Davis former head of Scotland yards
Royal protection command interested to
talk to you thank you
my pleasure and do you make sure to stay
with us as new details emerge on this
story we'll be live from New York at
seven o'clock on Sky News tonight and
we'll have continuing coverage
throughout the evening on Sky News at 10
and the Press preview